hey 42 here laughing so hard that no
noise comes out is actually good for
your health it reduces your risk of
heart disease welcome to RIF about one
in every four million lobsters is born
with a rare genetic defect that turns it
blue and one in every 30 million
lobsters is yellow the mimic octopus
doesn't just change color it can also
mimic the shape of other sea creatures
like the lionfish and sea snakes the
left lung is smaller than the right lung
to make room for the heart the original
Surveyors of Mount Everest lied and
added two feet to its height to make it
29,000 and two feet because they didn't
think that people would believe them if
they said it was really 29,000 feet high
bacteria can get viruses and viruses can
also get viruses the Canadian University
of Victoria offers a course in the
science of bat mark the United States
Liberia and Burma are the only countries
in the world that have not officially
adopted the metric system as their
standard of measurement sea horses form
monogamous lifetime relationships and
travel in pairs holding each other's
tails a fortunate 2% of the population
have a genetic variation that doesn't
cause any body odor when they sweat
Ashton Kutcher tried Steve Jobs's
fruitarian diet when getting into
character for the jobs movie and ended
up in hospital because it seriously
messed up his pancreas levels Steve Jobs
died of pancreatic cancer
99% of all the species that have ever
lived are now extinct the praying mantis
has only one ear which is located
between its legs
modern homing pigeons find it easier to
follow motorways and turn left and right
at junctions instead of using their
inbuilt navigational abilities more than
one in five Americans believes that the
world will end in their lifetime Wars
kill more civilians than soldiers in a
war the safest place to be is usually in
the army
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you